c'est une je dire une forme de de
défaite pour le bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions euh
une victoire politique inédite euh aussi
euh c'est un voyez je suis partagé vous
le senté dans mon propos un partager
entre la satisfaction de voir un
texte mauvais euh dégager du débats
parlementaires dans des formes encore
une fois très originales euh mais euh je
vois aussi a les réactions des uns des
autres qui consistent à dire mais c'est
le mariage de la carpe et du lapin entre
le Ren d'un côté et la gauche de l'autre
qui a abouti à cela c'est surtout une
défaite personnelle pour mon juste pour
revenir là-dessus on va parler de Gérald
harmanin Gérald armanin justement il dit
c'est l'alliance des contraires qui se
sont mis d'accord pour des raisons
politiques Aï est-ce qu'il a pas raison
mais qu'est-ce que voulez que je vous
dise monsieur Darmanin a joué la
confusion il a perdu quand ici au Sénat
pendant une semaine il a dharmanisé le
texte euh en donnant des gages en
permanence à LR pour avoir un vote
positif qu'il a obtenu en faisant
supprimer le fameux article 3 et
l'article 4 sur l'intégration par le
travail en durcissant la circulaire Vals
qui permettait quand même cette
régularisation pour des gens de bonne
volonté qui n'ont envie que de
s'intégrer dans notre pays en supprimant
le l'aide médicale d'État en en
associant à 50 présences sur le
territoire des gens qui pourraient
obtenir dans la venir des allocations
familiales en fait rappelez-vous le
propos de Monsieur Darmanin qu'est-ce
qu'il avait dit il avait dit nous serons
gentils avec les gentils méchants avec
les méchants à la fin du texte on était
devenu méchant avec les gentils et puis
méchant tout court donc il a donné des
gages ici au Sénat et puis bom
changement de d'attitude changement de
décor à l'Assemblée où là il dit mais
finalement le texte du Gouvernement
initial est très bien donc il a créé la
confusion c'est l'arroseur arrosé la
confusion a était sanctionnée
hier